an nfl player arrested new orleans
running back alvin kamara taken into
custody on battery charges after
sunday's pro bowl now the victim in this
case is now out of the hospital victoria
saha has a look into the events that led
up to kamara's arrest
the victim who was identified as darnell
green talked to police from his hospital
bed at sunrise hospital around 6 pm
saturday evening according to an arrest
report greene told police that he was
leaving dre's nightclub on the strip
around 6 30 saturday morning as he was
stepping onto the elevator with a large
group next to him a man later identified
as alvin kamara put his hand on green's
chest stopping him from walking onto the
elevator green then pushed camara's hand
off green tells police he was hit and
kicked by multiple people green was able
to remember camaro's involvement by his
looks and the clothing he was wearing
police say security footage supports
green's accusations on sunday kamara
played in the 2022 pro bowl at allegiant
stadium where he was arrested after the
game the arrest report says camaro was
interviewed by police at the stadium and
he tells police he saw a fight break out
and saw green get punched police say
camaro told them he punched green
several times because he thought he did
something to the group and he was trying
to run away but the report says
surveillance video showed green was not
running away and had just been punched
by one of camaro's friends and camara
immediately attacked him green suffered
an eye injury but has since been
discharged from sunrise hospital
victoria zaha live local now